♪ ♪
>> Dana: BRAND-NEW FALLOUT
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMUTED
THE THREE-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE
FOR HIS FORMER ASSOCIATE
ROGER STONE.
TOP DEMOCRATS ARE LESS THAN
AMUSED.
>> IT STANDS FOR CORRUPTION, BUT
IT LETS PEOPLE KNOW THAT IT IS A
THREAT TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THIS IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES COULD BE SO BRAZEN
AS TO COMMUTES AND PARDON OF HIS
FRIENDS WHO ARE PROTECTING HIM.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT
THROUGH THE COMMUTATION
BASICALLY IS SAYING IF YOU LIVE
FOR ME, IF YOU COVER UP FOR ME,
IF YOU HAVE MY BACK, THEN I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET A GET OUT
OF JAIL FREE CARD.
>> Dana: AND HERE IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTING TODAY.
>> THEY FOUND NOTHING INITIALLY,
BUT IT WENT ON FOR TWO YEARS OR
LONGER, AND I DID -- I AM
GETTING RAVE REVIEWS FOR WHAT I
DID FOR ROGER STONE, AND HE
FRANKLY IS GOING TO GO AND
APPEAL HIS CASE.
HE HAD A JURY POOR WOMAN WHO
HATED ROGER STONE, AND WHO HATED
PROBABLY ME.
BUT SHE WENT UNDER FALSE
PRETENSES, NOT GIVEN A FAIR
TRIAL.
WAS NOT GIVEN ANOTHER TRIAL.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN ANOTHER
TRIAL.
>> Dana: JESSE, ONE OF THE
MOST SURPRISING THINGS ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS REACTION WAS THAT THEY
WERE SURPRISED.
THE MOVE WAS TELEGRAPHED FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
>> Jesse: I JUST CAN’T GET
OVER TRUMP’S HAIR RIGHT THERE.
DID ANYBODY NOTICE THE SIZE OF
THE HAIR?
>> Dana: THAT IS LIKE WITH YOU
NOT WEARING A TIE.
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY IS
CHANGING THEIR LOOK IN THE
PANDEMIC.
HONESTLY, HE HAS BEEN IN THE
GUTTER FOR DECADES, HE IS NOT A
CRIMINAL.
HE IS AN OLD MAN WHO LIKES TO
TALK A LOT OF TRASH AND GOT
CAUGHT UP IN A FRAME JOB,
HONESTLY.
IF A GUY PLANTS A GUN ON YOU AND
IS A POLICE OFFICER AND YOU
THROW THE GUN IN THE RIVER, YOU
CANNOT BE CHARGED WITH
OBSTRUCTION, IT IS A DIRTY
INVESTIGATION.
AS WE KNOW IT’S BASELESS.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
IT WAS A WITCH HUNT, AND NOW THE
MEDIA IS MAD BECAUSE WITCH HUNT
GOT EXPOSED.
GENERAL FLYNN IS GOING TO WALK,
STONE IS GOING TO WALK.
LISTEN, IT IS HONESTLY -- I AM
TIRED OF LOOKING BACK AT THIS.
WE REALLY NEED TO GO FORWARD
WITH THE DEMOCRATS GETTING
CAUGHT, TRYING TO FRAME PEOPLE,
AND, YOU KNOW, CHELSEA MANNING,
GOT COMMUTED BY BARACK OBAMA.
HE CONSPIRED WITH WIKILEAKS.
ROGER STONE DID NOT CONSPIRE
WITH WIKILEAKS AND HE IS NOW IN
TROUBLE.
I MEAN, IT SEEMS BACKWARDS.
BILL CLINTON, DIDN’T HE PARDON
HIS BROTHER OR HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER?
BUT THIS IS THE CRAZIEST THING?
HE PARDON THE BIGGER TAX CHIEF
BECAUSE HIS WIFE GAVE $1 MILLION
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
COME ON!
A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO BRING
UP TO GREG, DO YOU REMEMBER THE
OBAMA COMMUTATION OF OSCAR
RIVERA.
AN ACTUAL TERRORIST, THERE IS
NOT AS MUCH OUTRAGE.
>> Greg: YES, THE LAST PERSON
WHO SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT AN
ABUSE OF POWER IS ADAM SCHIFF
WHO MARSHALED THE ENTIRE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING WHICH
CRIPPLED OUR GOVERNMENT HEARINGS
AND MEDIA HYSTERIA, WHILE WE
WERE SCREAMING AND POINTING TO
WUHAN SAYING, THERE IS A HUGE
THING GOING ON HERE.
BUT EVERYBODY WAS SO -- THE
MEDIA ON THE DEMOCRATS WERE SO
INTO IMPEACHMENT THAT WE DID NOT
GET AN EARLY START FIGHTING THE
VIRUS, AND INSTEAD NOW WE ARE
FACING LARGER ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH BECAUSE
WE WERE TOO BUSY TRYING TO
UNSEAT THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE WE
DID NOT LIKE AN ELECTION.
SO SAVE ME THE WHINING ABOUT
ROGER STONE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAPPENED AND
WHY WE WILL HEAR MORE IS THAT
ROBERT MUELLER WHO DID THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE PROSECUTOR
PROSECUTOR, HE WROTE AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT SAID
THAT THE JURY SPOKE, THAT THERE
IS A CONVICTION, NOW HE HAS
MAINTAINED THAT HE WILL NOT TALK
ABOUT IT.
HE WOULD LET HIS REPORT STAND.
BUT NOW THAT HE HAS WRITTEN IT,
LINDSEY GRAHAM FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA SAYS NOW YOU HAVE
GIVEN YOURSELF AND INVITATION TO
COME TESTIFY IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE.
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT IS GOOD
OR BAD FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
TO BRING ALL OF THE STUFF UP
AGAIN?
>> Juan: YOU MEAN POLITICALLY,
DANA?
>> Dana: YES.
>> Juan: POLITICALLY IT
PROBABLY IS GOOD IF YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE A REVIEW OF ALL
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST
WITH REGARD TO WHAT TOOK PLACE
IN TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT’S
CAMPAIGN AND ALL THE CONTACTS
WITH THE --
>> Jesse: NOTHING TOOK PLACE.
>> Juan: OF COURSE SOMETHING
TOOK PLACE, THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF CONTACTS AND THAT’S WHY --
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, OKAY, THE
CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
THAT THE CONVICTION WAS
APPROPRIATE AND UNLAWFUL.
AND HE OPPOSED WHERE THE
PRESIDENT DID.
I JUST THINK THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE WHO WATCH
OUR SHOW TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT SOME LIBERAL MEDIA GOING
BALLISTIC.
DO THAT TODAY YOU HAD THE
CONSERVATIVE NATIONAL REVIEW TO
START WITH THE PRESIDENT DID IN
COMMUTING THAT SENTENCE AS
INDEFENSIBLE.
YOU HAVE THE CONSERVATIVE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" EDITORIAL
PAGE DRAWING SOME OF THE
COMPARISONS BUT SAYING WHEN YOU
COMMUTE A FRIEND SENTENCE, THAT
IS AN ABUSE OF POWER IN THEIR
OPINION.
SO THOSE ARE CONSERVATIVE
OUTLETS SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO
WHAT TOOK PLACE.
AND I THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, EVEN WHEN CLINTON
PARDONED MARC RICH, HE DID IT AS
HE WAS ON HIS WAY OUT.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A THUMB IN
THE EYE TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
FROM A GUY THAT SAYS HE IS
MR. LAW AND ORDER WHEN IT COMES
TO A STREET CRIMINAL, BUT NOT TO
HIS FRIEND WHO HAS CLEARLY,
CLEARLY BROKEN THE LAW AND HAS
EVEN FORCED ROBERT MUELLER’S
HAND TO COME OUT AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS WRONG.
>> Dana: IT IS AN INTERESTING
COMPARISON, THUMB IN THE EYE,
BUT IT WAS LIKE THE THUMB IN THE
EYE TO THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I THINK.
>> Katie: YES, THIS SITUATION,
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT DENYING
THAT ROGER STONE COMMITTED A
CRIME, WHICH IS WHY HE DID A
COMMON TATIAN AND NOT A PARDON,
BUT THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW
ADAM SCHIFF IS MAKING THE
ARGUMENT THAT ROGER STONE LIED
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT, LIED
TO COVER IT UP, ARE WE REALLY TO
BELIEVE THAT THE ROBERT MUELLER
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
HINGED ON ROGER STONE?
THE ONE PERSON WHO MAY HAVE HAD
INFORMATION CONSIDERING HUNDREDS
OF SUBPOENAS, THOUSANDS OF
INTERVIEWS, THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS, MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
A WIDE-RANGING TEAM OF
PROSECUTORS THAT HAD ACCESS TO
ALL KINDS OF INFORMATION, WE ARE
REALLY TO BELIEVE FROM
ADAM SCHIFF THAT ROGER STONE IS
THE ONE PERSON WHO MADE IT ALL
JUST GO AWAY FOR THE PRESIDENT?
THAT IS LAUGHABLE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PRINCIPLE THAT
IF PEOPLE DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHO ENGAGED IN
CORRUPTION, BY THE WAY, BY USING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GO
AFTER A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN CAN
GET AWAY WITH LYING LIKE
ANDREW MCCABE, FOR EXAMPLE AS A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI, AND
THEY DON’T GO TO JAIL FOR IT,
THEN WHY SHOULD ROGER STONE GO
TO JAIL FOR IT?
IT IS A COMMUTATION, NOT A
PARDON, BUT THERE SHOULD NOT BE
A DOUBLE STANDARD BASED ON
POLITICS WHETHER YOU ARE
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN.
>> Greg: HEY, DANA.
>> Dana: YES, SIR.